This video is about an experiment
I've wanted to do for years and
the unexpected result I got when I did it.
Have you ever had a simple question ruin your
life?
Of course you have, right?
Like, it's perfectly normal to spend months
and months doing nothing else but obsessing
over a question that no one else cares about.
Like, does light actually slow down in water?
I know you probably think the answer is obvious,
like, definitely slows down, like we learned
that in high school, but I've never really
believed it.
Like, it just seems odd.
In Einstein's theory of relativity, the speed
of light is this super fundamental thing.
Like, no matter where you are in the universe
or what speed you're going at, you will always
find light to be travelling at the speed c.
Except in a glass of water.
I mean, how can that actually be true?
I stopped worrying about it for a while because
I thought there was no way to find out the
answer, until recently when I realized that
there is a way to accurately time how long
it takes for light to travel using
something called LiDAR.
And insanely, that technology just happens
to be in my phone.
Yeah, seriously, this bit of the phone that
I managed to smash recently, that thing measures
the time it takes for light to bounce off
an object and come back.
My phone uses that incredible technology just
to improve the focus in photos a little bit.
Insane.
So of course I tried to do this experiment.
Okay, it's angry.
No surface detected.
Come on.
This is ridiculous.
Uh, yeah, so that didn't work this time, but
eventually I did get it to work and it gave
me the answer.
It was just understanding that answer that
took months off my life.
The issue is that common explanations for
why light slows down in water are wrong, and
even the uncommon explanations for why light
slows down are also wrong.
So maybe light doesn't actually slow [00:02:00]
down at all.
Incredibly, that's exactly what one of my
favorite textbooks says.
We'll get to that, but first let's deal with
these.
Let's start with some explanations for why
light slows down that are so common.
You've probably heard them in school, but
they're completely wrong.
I think the most common one, and the one that
I believed for a while goes like this, you
have this light.
And when it travels between water molecules,
it's still going at the regular speed c.
But, what happens is when it bumps into a
molecule, it gets absorbed by that molecule
for a little while, and then later on released,
and then absorbed again, and released.
And this adds enough time lag to the whole
process that the particle has slowed down.
Light does sometimes get absorbed by molecules,
but we can tell that this explanation is wrong,
because when light does get absorbed, what
happens is it doesn't remember where it came
from, and it gets re emitted in any random
direction.
And so if we let it get re emitted,
in random directions, then that means that
overall the light doesn't go in a straight
line from A to B, but every bit of light spreads
out into all kinds of directions.
And so when you look at light in water, you
should expect that instead of going in a straight
line, it spreads out.
That's not what we see, and so that can't
be the right explanation.
Another reason you can tell this is false
is because molecules only want to absorb certain
frequencies of light.
That means only specific colors of light would
get absorbed and then re emitted, so everything
else should still travel at the speed c.
But that's not what supposedly happens.
Every type of light gets slowed down by water.
There's another common explanation that goes
wrong for exactly the same kind of reasons.
And this one says that what happens is the
light travels at the speed C between molecules,
but it knocks into the molecules and ricochets
around.
Which means that its path ends up being a
lot longer than it would have been.
You can see that this has the same
flaw.
It would mean that light should completely
spread out, but that's not what we see.
One thing to note about both of those wrong
explanations is they involve thinking of light
as a little particle like this.
Which, I can tell you, is almost always the
wrong way to think about light.
Like, yes, in some specific circumstances,
light acts like a particle, But not this kind
of particle.
And so I think that this is really an unhelpful
way to think about light.
And instead in this video, we're going to
talk about light as a wave, which I'll explain
later.
But anyway, going back to those explanations,
if those two other explanations are wrong,
then what are some other common explanations
that seem like they're more correct?
There was this other one that kept coming
up and it was about secondary waves.
In the videos I'd seen they'd usually make
three claims.
The first two turned out to be correct and
super important to the actual answer and the
third turned out to be
wildly [00:05:00] misleading.
Here they are.
When you shine light into water what happens
is that the original light just actually goes
through the water completely unaffected but
The electrons inside of the water do get affected
by the light, and because of the light, they
emit their own waves.
When you add up the original light plus all
of the light coming from the electrons, you
supposedly get light that's travelling slower.
Yeah, when I started this, I didn't understand
the first thing about that explanation.
And to get it, I had to go right back and
figure out, like, What light even is?
For that I turned to my two favourite textbooks
The Feynman Lectures in Physics and Matter
and Interactions And in the process I learned
so much that I wish I knew about light earlier.
We usually use the letter C to represent the
speed of light.
But, I'd argue it shouldn't be called that,
it should be called the
maximum speed of causality,
or even better, how quickly one thing can
affect another.
For example, imagine [00:06:00] this is the
sun, and this is the earth.
The earth is being held in its orbit around
the sun, by its attraction to the sun.
You might have heard, though, that if the
sun was to suddenly disappear, then Earth
wouldn't immediately be flung out into space.
Instead, it'll take about eight minutes, and
then it will be flung out into space.
Why is that?
It's because the message that the sun has
disappeared can only travel at a particular
speed, which is the speed C.
That is the quickest that one thing can affect
another.
C is actually the maximum speed in the universe,
because if there was an object that could
travel faster than C, then you could use it
to send messages faster than C, and that's
not allowed.
I used to think it was kind of a coincidence
that the speed of light was equal to the maximum
speed of causality.
Like, maybe it was just because light was
a massless particle or something like that.
But actually there's a really good reason
for it, and it makes a lot of sense when you
look at this next example.
Let's say I have these two electrons.
Now this electron feels a force because of
this one.
But say I picked up this one and I accelerated
it.
Would this electron immediately know about
this electron's new position and update the
force that it feels?
No, right?
Because it needs to wait until the message
from that particle arrives to it.
But what's actually delivering that message?
This is the key part.
Light is the messenger.
Whenever a charged particle accelerates, it
sends the message far and wide at the speed
C.
But when I realised what kind of messages
light sends, that's when I felt like I really
understood light for the first time.
Light's whole purpose is to harass charged
particles.
Imagine that I push this electron up and down,
then the light that it makes is going to be
shaped like this.
Here's what that means for the other electron
that gets into the path of that light.
If the light [00:08:00] gets up to here, then
this is supposed to be an arrow representing
how strongly the electron is going to get
punched upwards.
And then, as the light travels, it punches
it up even more strongly upwards and then,
as it passes here, it starts
to punch it downwards,
and upwards again, and then downwards.
The net result is that as this light passes,
this electron is pushed up and down.
Basically light is a packet of electrical
forces traveling through space.
Incidentally, this answers a question that
used to really bother me.
If light is a wave, then what's waving?
We're used to thinking about waves as something
like water waves, where there's a physical
medium that's sloshing about.
But that's not the type of wave that light
is.
Light is just a wavering of how strong the
electromagnetic force is at any point in space.
You can see that at this point in space right
now, the electric force points upwards, but
a little [00:09:00] bit later...
It will point even further up and then later
it will point down and that's what light is.
It's this field strength changing over time.
Here I've represented it with these poorly
made arrows because I think that's evocative
of like these forces and how they change over
time.
But usually the way you represent light is
with this wave and you can see that it represents
the exact same thing.
This wave is just capturing how strong the
forces are at every point, but it's just joined
up so it looks a little bit nicer and so you'll
see these pictures of like light as a wave
traveling through space, but it's the same
thing.
The thing that's waving is the strength of
the magnetic force, not any medium.
Back to our poor electron, we know that as
this light passes it, it will oscillate up
and down.
But, we know exactly what happens to oscillating
charged particles.
They're accelerating, so they're making light.
The light that this [00:10:00] electron makes
is actually exactly the same as the light
that originally hit it.
Except it's in the opposite direction and
usually it's a bit weaker.
But what's the effect of these two bits of
light combined?
Well let's look at it from the perspective
of another electron that's further down the
line.
Is it going to experience two separate pieces
of light?
Well actually no, because remember light is
just a bunch of electric forces.
So when this piece of light tries to push
this electron downwards, this piece of light
is going to be trying to push it upwards,
but a little bit more weakly.
You can see that that happens everywhere.
When this one pushes up, the other one pushes
down, but a little bit weakly.
And so it's like this one slightly negates
the effect of this one.
It's actually a really similar effect to how
active noise cancelling works.
So when the headphones detect a particular
wave of sound, they make their own sound,
which is in the opposite direction.
The crazy thing is, when you add
these two pieces of sound, you get much less
sound.
And that's what this electron is doing as
well.
When it gets hit with light, it hits back
with its own light that partially negates
the original.
So that was my mini crash course in light,
and now we can just use those ingredients
to figure out whether that explanation about
why light slows down in water actually makes
any sense.
Remember, the first bit was that this light
enters the water and is completely unaffected
by the water and goes right through.
So far, we know that that bit is correct.
And then it says that The electrons that are
inside of this water then react by making
their own light, which makes sense because
remember as this light goes through, it makes
all of these electrons jiggle up and down
and jiggling electrons make light.
And it is true that each of these electrons
responds by making their own light.
When you add the original light with the light
from all of these electrons, you
would expect something interesting to happen.
I mean, we've already seen that when waves
add up, they can do interesting things like
cancel out.
But the YouTube videos in particular would
use these animations to try and explain how
when you add this piece of light that's traveling
at the speed C, with these other pieces of
light that are all also traveling at the speed
C, you get some light.
that isn't travelling at the speed c.
This is the original light, and this is what
the light from the electrons looks like.
And you can see that they're moving at the
same speed because they don't move relative
to each other.
In other words, they always keep in time with
each other.
Now let me just add them together and the
result is this other light that does move
relative to the original pieces of light and
so it must have a different speed to the other
two.
When I saw these animations I couldn't [00:13:00]
understand how they were working but I felt
that I had to accept it because they'd shown
me proof.
But here's the insane thing.
When I was making this video, I finally tried
to just replicate their little demonstration
just to see for myself and like to understand
it.
So I did it exactly the way that they said
they've done it and they do not work.
Here we got the original light and the electron
light which is in a similar form and then
we're just going to add them together.
And they don't move relative to each other.
I was so mad when I realised that these things
are just straight up lies.
You can't add two pieces of light that are
going at the speed c and expect to get light
that's going slower.
It just doesn't work mathematically.
And they usually mention the difference between
phase velocity and group velocity at this
point to try and explain how this could work,
but that just muddies the water.
I had to go and try and understand what those
two things mean, and now I know that that
phenomena is only relevant if you already
have waves [00:14:00] that are going at different
speeds.
So, what the hell.
You won't believe this, but as I was trying
to make this animation for you, I realized
what was going wrong, and it's actually kind
of ridiculous, and I can't even be mad about
it.
Basically, I think that they accidentally
left off a set of brackets.
Here is this electron wave, and it's supposed
to be traveling at the same speed, see?
Which it is right now, but if I accidentally
forgot about this set of brackets now Even
though the wave looks like it's the same.
It's actually not it's traveling at a different
speed And so now the two waves are not traveling
at the same speed C And so of course when
you add them, they're not going to travel
at the speed C either and you can see that's
what happens It's slightly annoying, but I
think this was just an honest mistake.
After I realised that these videos don't work,
I turned to textbooks that I trusted, and
they seemed to point to another possibility.
Maybe light doesn't slow down at all.
The Feynman lectures on this topic start off
with a kind of cryptic statement
that seems to suggest light doesn't really
slow down.
It says, It is approximately true that light
does appear to slow down, but all contributions
of the field are travelling at the ultimate
velocity c.
So in other words, the
original light is travelling
at the speed c, and so are all the other pieces
of light.
But maybe when you add them all up, they just
appear to be travelling slower.
I don't know.
The statement was a little bit cryptic, so
I wasn't 100 percent sure what it meant.
But on the other hand, my other favourite
textbook was completely unequivocal.
It put it very bluntly.
It asks you to imagine this experiment.
Your friend aims a laser at your location,
precisely at time t1, and turns on the laser.
You record the time t2 at which you detect
the light.
Knowing the distance between your locations,
you can calculate the speed.
In this case, it will still give 3 x 10^8 meters per second, even
though there's water in the way.
Or to put it another way, if you measure the
speed of light in water using the most sensible
method, which is to take the distance of this
container and then just dividing it by the
time that it takes for light to get from one
side to the other, you get that the speed
of light in water.
is actually just equal to C. In other words,
light doesn't actually slow down in water.
This is a very testable prediction and so
I tried to test it.
For this I'm going to use the LiDAR in my
phone and the fact that it pulses light.
And it measures how long it takes for that
light to get back.
Alright, so I'm about to dunk my phone in.
And right now, before it's in the water, it's
saying that there's about 30cm to the other
side.
That's um, way outside of the range
that I measured.
I want to clear up one
thing about this measurement
because it's quite confusing.
So, the thing that my phone can measure is
actually time.
Specifically, the amount of time that it takes
to go from one side of the container, get
reflected, and come back.
But, it tells you that what it's measuring
is the distance.
How is that possible?
Well, it uses the fact that distance is equal
to the speed times the time taken, so the
time taken is the thing that it actually measured,
but it cheats because it assumes that the
speed of light is always c.
And since c is a well known constant, it can
use that value and the time taken that it
measured to give you a distance.
And that hack should work most of the time,
unless you happen to be doing this experiment
underwater, and the speed of light in water
really is slower than sea.
So supposedly, light is supposed to slow down
to about three quarters of its
original speed when it's in water, which is
a huge slowdown, which will absolutely mess
up this distance measurement, because this
distance is measured.
using c as the speed when it should be c times
three quarters.
If you know the actual distance here and you
compare it to what your phone says, if it
says that the new distance is longer, that's
because it wasn't correctly accounting for
the fact that light slows down in water.
But if you did this experiment and you found
that the distance is actually the real distance,
then that means that the time taken hasn't
actually changed, which means that the speed
is exactly the same as well.
So that means that if the phone measures the
distance correctly, the speed of light in
water is actually not reduced.
It's still equal to C. And that was exactly
what I was expecting to find.
This reading doesn't even make sense outside
of water.
This was a recurring theme.
The phone readings disagreed with the actual
distances even when there was no water.
A fatal flaw in my plan?
Perhaps, but I pushed on anyway.
Okay, whatever.
So if I double tap on the screen... accuracy
at 26.
9%... Oh no, it just actually says it!
Okay, this is perfect.
Alright.
So let's put in...
Come on, talk to me.
This was also a recurring theme.
Every time I tried to put the phone in water,
it refused to believe that there was a surface
worth detecting.
Okay, I'm back.
Um...
I think this is going to work.
Here I've got this container that is nine
and a half centimeters tall.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to sit my
phone on top of it, then this time I'm going
to pour some water in and see how the [00:20:00]
measurement changes as we go.
And, like, if the speed of light is the same
whether we're in water or not in water, then
distance shouldn't change, because the time
that it takes for light to go from the top
to the bottom should be exactly the same.
How clever.
It says that the height of this is actually
11 centimetres.
Which is a bit different from what I measured,
but it doesn't matter.
It does matter.
No, please work, please work.
Why is it suddenly not detecting anything?
Yeah, that didn't work and it didn't work
the next four times either.
Even though I hadn't yet done the experiment,
I was pretty sure about what the results were
going to be because of this very simple argument.
Imagine we have this light coming from this
light source.
If there was no water in the way, We know
that this would travel through at the speed
c, but even if there is water there, we know
that the original light will travel through
[00:21:00] unimpeded, so it's still traveling
at the speed c.
The only difference is that there's now a
second source of light.
Every time this original
light gets to a particular
layer, the electrons in that layer are going
to get oscillated by that light.
And they are going to produce their own light,
which I'm going to represent like this because
it's some complicated thing that comes from
adding all of the light from all of the electrons
in that layer.
But it's some sort of light here.
Now in terms of timing, there's one very crucial
fact.
And that is, there's no time lag between the
time that this light enters this slayer and
this, these electrons start jiggling and produce
their own light.
And that's because electrons produce their
own light as soon as they feel any acceleration.
So the moment that this non zero force hits
this electron, it will start oscillating and
it will produce light.
And so there's no time lag at all.
That means that whenever this light gets to
a new layer, Immediately there'll be some
light from those electrons But remember when
we're talking about the [00:22:00] speed of
light in water What we're interested in is
not the original light or the light coming
from the electrons But the sum of those two
lights again, we don't know what it is But
it's going to be some complicated thing The
question though is how fast does this overall
light travel through the water and in particular
we want to know Does it keep up with the original
light going at the speed C, or does it go
slower?
Here's my argument for why it has to keep
going at the same speed as the original light.
Remember, the moment that this light gets
to this layer, it will immediately produce
some light from the electrons, which will
then sum, immediately, to some resulting light.
And so the resulting light has also reached
the same layer in the same time.
These three bits of light have kept in time
with each other which means that this resulting
light must have been traveling at the same
speed as the original.
So they're both traveling at the speed c.
So there you go, light really doesn't slow
down in water.
But then, why do you get the effects as if
light slows down in water, like the wavelength
of light [00:23:00] decreasing, and like the
light bending when it hits water?
Well, the Feynman lectures explain how you
get those effects from first principles, and
Grant from 3Blue1Brown has made a very beautiful
video explaining that whole proof, so I highly
recommend that you watch that.
So I'm not going to go over that proof here,
but I do want to give you the very basic gist
of it, and it all comes down to the fact that
you can't send messages faster than the speed
of light.
Imagine our light now goes through a thin
slice of water.
We know that what actually happens is that
the original light just keeps going through
that material at the speed c and doesn't care
at all.
But, the electrons inside of that material
are disturbed by the passage of light.
And they start oscillating.
There's one important thing that I haven't
yet told you about the light coming from these
electrons.
So far I've been representing it as if the
light from this electron only goes in the
forward direction.
But that's not actually true.
Each of these electrons starts to radiate
in many different directions.
However, it most strongly radiates
forwards and backwards.
It does radiate in the other directions as
well.
Now, why does this matter?
Well, you might have thought that if you had
an electron here, it would only be affected
by the original light and light coming from
the electron directly in front of it.
But that's not true.
Actually, it does receive some light from
all of the other electrons.
The reason why that's so critical is this.
The electron that's right in front of it is
the shortest distance away.
But this electron, for example, is much further,
and remember that nothing travels faster than
the speed of light.
So, even though all of these are actually
bouncing in unison with each other, it's not
going to look like that from the perspective
of this electron, because it takes some time
for every message to be delivered, right?
And the further away, the longer that that
message is going to take.
Because messages can only travel at the speed
c.
Imagine that these [00:25:00] two are bouncing
in unison, and this particular bounce makes
this first little peak of light.
So far, these bits of light are in unison
with each other, but now let's consider the
bit that's going to arrive at this electron.
Here, I better turn this one.
By the time this one has arrived, they're
actually pretty out of sync with each other.
This peak that used to be in time with that
peak is now actually in time with this trough,
and so these two partially cancel each other
out.
In fact, if you add up the light from all
of the previous electrons on an electron that's
in the next layer of the water, then what
you get is all these bits of light that are
actually quite out of sync with each other.
Even though the electrons really were bouncing
in unison from this electron's point of view,
they're not in unison.
When this electron looks at one
of the further away electrons, it's looking
at what that electron was doing back in time.
It's actually the exact same effect that explains
why when you look at very distant objects
in the night sky, you're actually seeing how
they were in the past.
It's the fact that the electron's light is
out of date when it gets to the next layer.
that overall gives the impression that all
of the light is lagging behind.
I read and reread Feynman's chapter on the
refractive index for ages, but I remember
the day when it all finally clicked.
I was so happy because it felt like I just
understood something very fundamental.
I remember how happy I was so clearly because
genuinely the next day This happened.
Hi.
I'm panicking right now.
One of my friends suggested that I try out
this thing called ChatGPT.
He was saying that, like, you know, it's really
good at answering questions, especially, like,
factual questions, and so I should give it
a go.
And I wanted to ask a physics question,
so I just asked, um, does light slow down
in water?
It said yes, followed by a bunch of nonsense,
and I said arrogantly, I don't think so.
Has there been any experiments to prove this?
And the answer it gave me has got me really
panicked.
Yes, there have been many experiments that
have shown that light slows down when it passes
through water.
In particular, it mentioned an experiment
done by Huygens using a telescope.
But that's ridiculous because there's not
exactly a bunch of water between here and
the moon.
I pointed that out and it did concede, but
it said that many, many, many other people
had done this experiment.
And it was so confident that I started to
get worried.
I don't know what to believe, I guess.
I mean, I did all this Math, and I thought
that that was, um, definitive, and then now
some AI is telling me that, [00:28:00] uh,
I'm completely wrong, and that people have
actually done this experiment that I, uh,
am about to do, and they got a different result
from what I expected.
You can't make this stuff up.
So anyway, um,
so yeah, I decided that I had to just do this
experiment myself and I wanted to do it in
a way that would 100 percent convince me that
it was the right result.
Um, and I wouldn't be second
guessing it afterwards.
So I decided that I'm going to buy a proper
laser meter from the hardware store.
I'm in the car right now because it's pouring
and I'm just waiting it out.
So yeah, uh, you want to buy that?
And hopefully that will give me the right
results.
Let's see, I got the laser meter and now what
I'm going to do is that same experiment again.
I'm going to test how far this meter thinks
the distance is from the top of the shrug
to the bottom.
And I'm going to do it once without
water and then once with water.
Okay.
It gives me 11.2cm.
If the old distance is like 11cm,
then the new distance should be approximately
something around 14.5
Okay, so if the result is like approximately
11 centimeters, then that means that the speed
of light in water is about the same, whereas
if it's about 14.5
then, um, it means that
the speed is significantly slower.
So, let's see.
Okay,
aiming for about the same spot, and...[00:30:00]
I think that's a positive result.
So I've been thinking about maybe whether
this doesn't work the way that I think it
does.
So it turns out there are two types of LiDAR.
Um, there is one that's called phase based
LiDAR and if you use that sort of LiDAR, um,
it should give you a smaller speed of light
because it's just based on the phase and we
know that the phase is delayed.
There is a possibility that this is a phase
based LiDAR.
Um, I think that's unlikely but It might be
why I'm getting the wrong result, or like,
what seems like it should be the wrong result.
But there is another type of lighter, and
that's called time of flight lighter, and
it does exactly what you'd expect.
It pulses light very, very quickly, and then
that light comes, um, hits an object and bounces
back, and it measures the time difference
between when the [00:31:00] light was sent
and when it arrives back.
So, I want to make sure that what I use is
a time of flight lighter, because that should
give me the result that...
light travels at the same speed, no matter
what medium it's in.
And I was a bit skeptical about whether the
LiDAR in here would be time of flight, because
it seems like such an impossible task.
You know, you have to be pulsing these lasers
incredibly fast.
And then not only that.
when it comes back, you have to be able to
very accurately and quickly measure the light
and how long it took.
And these are very, very short timescales
that we're talking about, like, you know,
the time that it takes light to go from the
top of this jug of water to the bottom is
almost nothing.
Um, but it turns out.
The LiDAR in here really is a time of flight
LiDAR.
Uh, it uses some really cool technology, I
was reading the patterns for it, and yeah,
it's kind of amazing.
Um, it actually has a single photon avalanche
detector in it, which, uh, I really want one
of those.
So, yeah.
[00:32:00] This is the real deal and let's
do the experiment again and see if we get
the same result.
It turns out that a big part of what I was
doing wrong last time was that I had the phone
way too close to the water and at such short
distances, so I'd say like
less than 20 centimetres,
it's really bad.
But the phone seems quite good once you have
distances of about 30 centimetres.
So here I've got this saying that this distance
from here to the table is about 31 centimetres
But if I instead use this, um, I get a distance
of 30.6 so very similar
So these two ways of measuring the speed of
light agree for now when there's no water
in the way, but let's see what happens when
I move the water.
And now it's saying... that this distance
is 33.6 or so.
[00:33:00] Let's see if this agrees.
Whoa, look at this, 33.9
So they agree.
So I really am wrong.
Okay.
In the next video I investigated why light
actually slows down, but before you watch
that I'd highly recommend the video on 3Blue1Brown
on this topic.